oh
[Music]
[Music]
got to be careful here
this place is crawling with them
what was that what
cover me
guys hey guys
hey guys
oh thank god
and we started a community of survivors
y'all come live with us
[Music]
wait how did you know
come on
redneck wants us to move into his
community
us
let's go
[Music]
guys over here
oh thank god there are others
would you let me date your daughter of
course
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
please don't hurt me uh
my best friend's black and i love jay-z
and uh my favorite movie is think like a
man
she's good come with us
stay close okay what's your name emily
of course it is
what do you think about the police
i left the third album
i i i don't have any money i have no
money
oh my god oh my god thank god you guys
showed up i got to get out of here
it's a silver lexus just pull it right
up front and don't scuff the paint all
right i just had it buffed
was he an alien too yup
[Music]
there's got to be another human being
out there
somewhere
[Music]
it's been
173 days since the undoing
today
i may be the last man alive
however
if there is another
i will find them
the loneliness is more than i can
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa hey
dude uh hey oh oh come over there dude
hey
i'll come to you man
[Music]
[Music]
there's got to be another human being
out there
somewhere
the zombies have broken through i repeat
zombies
oh my god
tommy's been bad
[Music]
what are you waiting for you know what
you have to do god i i can't do it you
have to do it
forgive me
i can't believe the zombies met him
zombies are raccoons right
no it's just zombies
oh
you just killed tommy
all right listen up
sheriff's department's close by we'll be
safe there okay
stay close
i'll get you out of here
all right keep it together yeah okay we
gotta make it to the sheriff's station
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
we got to go through them just stay
together keep moving and don't get bit
go
hey
are you getting this yeah what is up
all right let's go
[Music]
[Music]
these are some racist [ __ ]
zombies why would you even lock the door
i mean the window's broken and
oh
oh hell no no no no
oh um oh what is that they seriously
wouldn't let her eat us
hey guys
isn't this great
these racist zombies are leaving us
alone
come on we're having a party
the beer is here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]